this sow is a real room
already votes really real um I taste
real that was really funny aware that
and now you taste fear yeah you taste
real alright
you taste real bad oh no big shower this
morning that that was great to get that
what Happy Meal box did you get that off
of oh you're real right you taste real
bad huh
anyway roses room we finally go in sake
roses room which I do you know Rose had
a room um why wouldn't she they all have
rooms
well she's I think did they talk like
she's dead there's a way you just blow
up the room well you build a solid baby
presence seems like it's kind of fucking
insane but you know obviously Steve just
didn't know how to use it I guess um no
you want a good time
this genius over here oh wow it's
activated roses room roses room which
ones rose again oh my god I got it
fucking money I picked it up and picked
it up um you know but the animal is
pretty fuckers David ah but yeah so
here's what they go on a mission he
plays this golf game that I think the
world's most boring RTG yeah Ozzy I
thought it looked both like
simultaneously so exciting and boring at
the same time as other reasons I loved
it I think it's a ball games like golf
not so much like it's I think it's
supposed to be like golf Pokemon
something like looks like if you crossed
pokemons with Final Fantasy yeah the
little like you said the tokine thing
the myth roll it's really the myth the
myth roll Club oh god there that was
nice I want am it through club its nyam
pervious to anything and orcs gonna hit
with it I do right it's fine cuz he was
talking about it you know you unlock the
secret ending and it was a big deal for
him to see the ending and I do remember
growing up it's like that was a big deal
it's like you know we work so hard now
we want to see what kind of ending they
give us Oh with an intensity ending yeah
you got really pissed off but when you
get her some game saying we would spend
hours and hours to win them and then
just be like thanks for playing come
graduation you are a winner yeah I'd be
like what um but yeah that was like a
big deal and now it's like when you play
a game you get to the ending it's like
no you're gonna discover something it's
gonna like change your fucking life or
something like that here's the twist on
this character or the entire world is
this or something it's like now they're
like holy shit or it'll be like or it'll
be like some really nicely pixelated
stuff what's really cool or it'll be
like Mass Effect or something that's
only life-changing because you realize
how disappointing it is but um yeah so
that's gonna fly you thinking back it's
like yeah I'm really looking forward to
those endings and now they're like not
even the tiniest bit innocent compared
to what they have now um but yes I know
what phrase these kids they were still
cool he plays this game uh and he
doesn't get to see a secret ending and
but then there's some sort of device
that what I'm doing it was just really
loud made it like a sound like cracked
all the screens and stuff like that um
so he feels like he wants to have his
own plays his own a place to get away
and even though he's been playing that
game for hours I would sort of say
that's a good like he certainly has tied
to himself but he you wanted to fill a
room and the room opens up the gym opens
up roses room and he goes if it
understood him yes and actually I had to
think I travelled apparently they try to
warn him about something he goes in the
room and then finds out it is an
unspeakable demo of terror wars which
really looks fluffy and nice and cloudy
and it's at first it's really nice but
then he figures out like he can't quite
get out of it he thinks is his town is
really his town but it's not it's still
the room room and as I said terrors I I
think you probably could play when the
father's trying to give advice and
various like yeah it's like it's an old
house ashes that was fun and we still
won't get arrested the important thing
is you told the truth and say yeah like
all the sayings you with you're on full
house um say these are making less sense
than usual bad so uh then the world
starts to crumble so a pretty cool way I
mean just through those jump cuts I
thought that was a pretty cool way of
showing and doing it and but he
eventually gets out and realizes that
you know there's no place like home I
guess something like that but that hey
it's good to have your own stone place
but it's also good to you know not rush
into things uh and yeah that's about it
something that I forgive I point out in
this episode of the last one uh have we
seen rose yeah we see like the bio we
seen the face yet I don't think so her
pictures up there I forget major but I
don't think they ever show the face yet
i I think the keyhole areas if it's just
the face of Stephen Apple didn't fall
far from her um so uh yeah I mean I get
I sort of felt like this was even though
there's a lesson at two I felt like it
was kinda setting up like hate so this
room can do this kind of you don't fully
have it figured out but I have this
really we will be seeing it again yeah
that's my thought too um so which again
on the one hand it's like I'm pissed off
I don't know more about mall so like I'm
intrigued because I'm always wondering
houses going you know a lot like the the
fuse in the last one like as soon as
they did that's like wow the stuff you
could do the combinations and then they
did that great fuse with uh with garnet
and amethyst that it's like it's cool
just it's like yes okay they're finally
starting to dabble with this and so they
with the lion taking them to a different
place and stuff uh so I don't like
trying to put a puzzle together only you
get one piece at a time yeah and they
don't all fit right next to each other
so you you get ideas at the very end
you're gonna boys staring yeah you're
gonna be staring at all these pieces be
like oh shit I gotta put this puzzle
together like but that could be kind of
fun I don't know no it's uh it's it's
definitely um every piece is interesting
to look at yes
uh and I was the other thing I was gonna
say oh the one thing that uh you know
cuz like I said before I think garnets
my favorite so far like she's just
really really cool but what I like about
her as well is that you know she's she
tough straight-faced cool and everything
but like you know when he says you know
I just say five cans of orange it just
goes cool it wasn't like you know I so
don't care like she's trying to still be
a little support just cool you know like
to us we can catch she's not interested
to a kid you know it sounds like a legit
good for you well done you know like
she's not gonna be like there was no
time we're children stuff or something
like that she's still trying to be
really super cool and I uh such good
delivery - it's such a minimal talk in
acting but it like it still really works
I usually watch few words but when she
says them they can't yeah and there they
are cool they're just really cool uh so
yeah I think anything else I think
that's uh it's not all I got on this one
just again just oh what's going on with
the room and how's it gonna come back
and everything um so I can't really
comment too much until we see how but a
good lesson very creative and uh onion
came back still don't fucking like it I
love the way you say it's like well we
know he's the same a lady remains
unchanged yeah I think it's just as
weird as on that fucking fry guy Oh
soulless eyes net bunny smile hmm sorry
five nights at Freddy's oh my god oh god
no I know you want to think about it but
uh yeah nope good stuff and I'll just we
will just see you at the next one
till then charlie